[Music]
hi it's Michele from lab - beauty
science here chemistry PhD and fan of
research-based skincare today I'm going
to be talking about the science behind
two very popular Neutrogena products
that ultra gentle daily cleanser and the
clear pore cleanser and mask I think
there's this idea that picking the right
cleanser is just about low PH and these
two are low pH but there's a lot more to
cleanser formulations than just that
this video is sponsored by Neutrogena
and I'm super grateful that they think
my content is worth supporting if you
like noting out about the science behind
beauty products make sure you subscribe
and click the notification bell so don't
miss any videos Neutrogena ultra gentle
daily cleanser is one of my new favorite
drugstore cleansers
it's a foaming cleanser which is my
favorite type because it spreads over
skin nicely and washes off easily I know
this is common perception that fobian
cleansers are harsh and stripping and
this comes from the fact that for a long
time the only ingredient that would foam
really well was sodium lauryl sulfate
this ingredient is usually a bit on the
harsher side unless you formulate with
it very carefully but in the last few
decades chemists have realized that you
can blend together gentler ingredients
and still get a really nice firm so this
cleanser even though it foams really
well doesn't contain harsh surfactants
surfactants are the cleaning ingredients
in cleansers this cleanser uses
hydrophobic we modify polymer technology
which was developed by scientists at
Neutrogena generally the harshest
ingredients in the cleanser are the
surfactants basically this cleanser has
ingredients that act like a little
reservoir for the surfactants so they're
all clean together into one big mass
when it's clumped together the
surfactants actually foam better in the
cleanser the clump is also too big to
get into skin and irritation and that
means that it's actually gentler and
less irritating than some non foaming
cleansers but the surfactant molecules
can still detach one by one from this
clump and so it still acts as an
effective cleanser that gets rid of dirt
and grease on your skin so this doesn't
have that harshness or stripping that
you might expect from a cleanser that
foams up and clean
skin effectively this also has a ton of
my favorite humectant ingredient
glycerine glycerine is really good at
holding on to water so it acts like a
little sponge that sits on your skin and
keeps it hydrated this is particularly
important in a cleanser because
cleansing is generally the harshest step
in a skincare routine wet skin is also
more permeable which means that during
and after you cleanse that's when your
skin is most prone to dehydrating and
glycerin helps counteract this effect
this cleanser is lightly fragrance the
fragrance is hypoallergenic and it
doesn't contain any known allergens or
essential oils I really like how this
cleanser doesn't strip my skin and it
leaves my skin feeling soft and smooth
my skin gets dehydrator really easily
especially right after I wash it so it's
really good to have a drugstore cleanser
that keeps my skin hydrated and happy it
also comes in a pump which is my
favorite type of packaging it makes it
super convenient to use the other
product I'm talking about in this video
is the clear pool cleanser or a mask
this is a product that's designed to
help with short contact therapy with
benzoyl peroxide it has 3.5% benzoyl
peroxide you can use this either as a
regular cleanser or you can put it on as
a masks that you wash off after about
five minutes benzoyl peroxide is a
classic acne treatment and it's so
effective that it's usually regulated as
a drug in most countries it's been used
for acne since the 1930s and it works in
a few different ways I think most people
know that it's antibacterial and asked
to kill the bacteria formerly known as
Propionibacterium acnes now called QT
bacterium acnes these bacteria are one
of the four contributing factors to acne
and it kills them in a way that doesn't
cause bacterial resistance it also acts
on two more contributions to acne it
prevents clogged pores and it reduces
inflammation a lot of people are
sensitive to benzoyl peroxide it causes
irritation in up to 40% of people who
use it you might get redness dryness
peeling and sting luckily it looks like
wash off products with benzoyl peroxide
work pretty well at treating acne and it
does it with less irritation it works in
a really short amount of time so you
don't have to leave it on your skin and
have it
irritate there's also the bleaching
issue benzoyl peroxide can break up dye
molecules and fabrics so complete
patches on your clothes pillowcases and
towels this product washes off so it's a
lot less likely to happen and it's
particularly good for treating acne on
your body because it's really hard to
avoid getting that on your clothes
this also has glycerin as the second
ingredient on the ingredients list and
that's really useful because it can
counteract the drying effect of benzoyl
peroxide most people will probably need
to use a moisturizer afterwards anyway
because benzoyl peroxide is quite harsh
and of course you need to wear a
sunscreen as well
there's also Kalyan and bentonite clay
which helps soak up oils which deals
with the fourth contributor to acne
which is excess oil production it's
actually the only clay mask that
actively kills bacteria as well I love
how easily the spreads on my skin and
washes off my skin is oily and acne
prone but sometimes I find benzoyl
peroxide still a bit too harsh because
I'm also quite prone to dehydration and
my skin is sometimes a bit dry from
using retinoids if I want to use benzoyl
peroxide without having an extra layer
on my skin or that extra irritation this
is great I usually put it on before I go
into the shower or even in the shower
and then wash my hair and then wash it
off this cleanser does have menthol in
it which gives it that tingling or
cooling effect and it's probably my only
complaint about this product especially
because I'm in Australia and we're
heading into winter and I am cold enough
I do know that a lot of people like that
refreshing feeling in their acne
products it's not bad for you it's just
a personal preference and it is actually
quite useful to tell if you've washed it
off properly before you go and blot your
face and get benzoyl peroxide everywhere
so that's my breakdown of those -
Neutrogena products the ultra gentle
daily cleanser and the clear pool
cleanser mask I hope you found this
video interesting let me know what you
thought of these products if you've
tried them before thanks again -
Neutrogena for partnering with me if you
like videos on the science behind beauty
products you can click the thumbs up and
subscribe to my channel you can also
check out my blog love muffin calm and
follow me on instagram at love muffin
Beauty sized for lots of little science
each in bits see you next time for
another sciency beauty video